we are back with worth it lifestyle
season
four we did it i have not been here for
any of the other ones all right i'm
taking credit
as our co-host we have jennifer
rutarello my good friend what's up
today we're doing backpacks so we're
gonna start off with a what's in my
backpack tour
all right hell yeah what do you got well
i always like to keep my toiletries in
there
my laptop an extra pair of socks and or
underwear depending on what's happening
i find that so fast some type of toy
i like to keep the essentials very
important products you have money from
i went to london earlier this year
that's enough out of me
what's happening in your neck of the
woods laptop of course my creative
journal
which i keep within the plastic wrapping
very midwestern mom of you
it makes me feel at home i have my
personal journal
and my bible and what i carry with me
all the time this is my protractor set
what do you use that for you just never
know when you need a straight edge
that's all
i rarely do you ready hit the road i'm
so ready let's do it
oh by the way we got annie and he loves
backpacks she don't know just so many
she's a backpack feeling as many
backpacks as i have kids
today on with a lifestyle we're gonna be
trying three backpacks actually
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its price
worth it baby it feels good to hear you
say that i like knowing exactly what
we're doing what's cool about backpacks
is that they're a gender-neutral option
that i think can be dressed up or
dressed down
because they're so versatile off the
flipping tumble off to flip a tumble
hi i'm eva this is heathole we're
co-founders of flip and tumble we're
here in our studio today and we're going
to check out our compactable backpack
flip and tumble great name uh where do
they come from so our first product
compacts down into a little ball
basically you're flipping the fabric
into that ball the ball can kind of
tumble around in your purse or every day
bag and split and tumble
i thought you guys were just like big
fans of gymnastics sorry we're not a
gymnastics studio
can you tell us a little bit more about
the backpack we're gonna be seeing today
so we were gonna show you
guys our full-size backpack the backpack
is actually made out of a material
called rpet
it's a really neat material made out of
ground up plastic bottles it's really
nice because it diverts plastic from the
landfill and it also allows us to make
the backpack using less energy
it doesn't rip no problems with that it
actually has a rip stop pattern in the
fabric and those checkers keep any small
holes from increasing in size
it also looks like it's pretty easy to
wash yes all of our products we make
sure they are all machine washable once
a bag is like hit like an airport
bathroom
right it's like a little bit dodgy after
that it was really important that this
worked for
lots of different things traveling
hiking if you're heading to the gym and
you just want to stash some
sneakers but we also wanted it to be
compactable so you could just stash it
in a suitcase
and you always just have this extra bag
handy designing a bag like this can you
just walk us through the process
so when we go to design a bag we usually
start with a need we see
first thing we do is start just
sketching where we can quickly iterate a
whole bunch of ideas and see which ones
we like and the next thing we do is we
like to make these little paper models
and fabric models so we can start to see
how those forms look in 3d
then we'll start making full-size
prototypes give them out to users and
then get feedback just do that until we
feel like okay we've got
a good product now jen let's let's try
the backpacks okay
so we're gonna try packing the backpack
now should we race
let's do it okay we need a countdown
you can put it in a backpack to carry
two backpacks mm-hmm
yeah and i can put it in my bra i love
things like this
just just i think you're too bold
it's right in there and what's nice is
it actually frames the face i'm actually
amazed at how easily these buckles
fit in there i was kind of worried they
would be disruptive to the process but
it's designed very well everything fits
i'm going to put the stuff that i would
carry around on a day-to-day basis
is that is that what you carry around
with you uh i
have more hold on
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
there you go okay see versatile oh
backpacks how do i look jen you look
cool the silver looks really good
because it matches your outfit my outfit
my hair
it is crazy how much you can fit in this
it is really comfortable actually
they actually have this sample backpack
that can hold the maximum weight
and it is a 35 full pound bag of sand
oh my god
would you ever pack your backpack this
heavy no wouldn't it yeah no
i'm not trying to be funny this is
legitimately hard for me to stand
this backpack can handle the weight i
cannot handle the weight but the
backpack is handling the weight very
well
all right off in new york flip tumble
what do you think
the fact that it had straps it had
buckles and it could still be rolled up
is pretty cool
backpack back oh we're doing that okay
hell yeah an early version of the modern
backpack was the book strap
which was really just a leather belt
that held your books together
you could then just throw the bundle
over your shoulder kids use these for
their school books from the 1900s
through the 1930s
anyone who's been to like a public
school knows that like the textbooks you
get are giant and
always hardcover and they weigh 75
pounds nowadays you like read textbooks
on tablets
yeah you can read ebooks now but it's
not the same
no it's not so where's our next location
we're going to
a tech oriented background a tech
oriented
all i'm gonna say my backpack is pretty
low tech but i do always try to carry
around
some type of charger some type of
electronics oh you might like this bag
you think so
okay teaser alert my interest
it is peaked my name's shane mcquade i'm
the founder of voltaic systems and today
we're going to look at the off-grid
backpack we started the company about 15
years ago with the solar backpack the
original idea i was actually living in
spain and i had this big clunky
charger that i was carrying around in my
bag getting lots of sun but
but never actually pulling this thing
out and i realized you know
somebody should stick that panel on the
outside of the bag if you were to
explain to a child how solar works
how would you explain it okay us yeah so
we start with the solar panel itself
we're using
sun power cells when sunshine hits that
material
it throws off an electron that gets
captured by the wires and those wires
channel that electricity back to a power
bank all of the bag is designed around
that panel
and the battery and we've got it in a
side pocket you can sort of swing the
bag around
take your phone out plug it back in
without necessarily taking the bag off
this thing is totally like rain proof
like you could take it out in the middle
of like a storm and it'd be like super
chill
you can yeah okay the bag is made from
recycled soda bottles actually so it's a
waterproof
fabric the panels themselves are really
tough we
threw one off a six-story building just
to see how it would go and it was fine
we've also driven my car over the panel
and at least on a flat surface it's fine
who are the clients out that are buying
this backpack well there's all the peace
corps volunteers writing to us every day
saying i'm going to be in this village
with no electricity for the next year
and then there's a whole bunch of people
doing
a humanitarian work doctors running
around after an earthquake
yeah without power nothing's working
they need to be able to communicate and
so it's really useful there
so where do you see the future of solar
there's still a billion people that
don't have any electricity a small panel
can run a cell phone and a light
and really change your life
first impressions i was surprised at how
you don't even know there's a solar
panel here wow this is a really deep
water bottle holder too
how deep it's pretty deep it's like
halfway up my forearm also it's just a
deep hole
this reminds me of your backpack my
backpack currently is like pretty large
but it's like a fabric backpack this one
has like
structural integrity i feel like would
make it a little bit more comfortable
when carrying heavy stuff
wow that's like a big tongue there's a
lot of pockets in here too where you
could put like
pens like little notepads and the side
pockets have their own little pouches
wow okay i have an idea jen yeah let's
create a hybrid jen
steven backpack amazing um do you think
you want to put in this
little compartment here yeah oh of
course yes
no no you know what you should go
sunglasses pouch
why didn't we think of that you got to
keep these safe too with the hard shell
exterior
oh we got a straight tampon here hold up
uh thanks buddy
okay maybe oh yes i have some candy
candy
of course i think we can shut him up
wait my protractor said oh okay yeah put
that in there
i think the real test is its ability to
actually
charge charge okay boom string
the cords through a little hole and
yeah charging green yeah look at that
it is a big backpack i will say that
it's it's large but the nice thing is
there is a smaller model so i could get
a smaller size if i wanted to do you
want to try it out i really wanted to
get it on
i mean yeah that's the perfect size for
a backpack for me yeah this actually i
feel like this looks really good
i wouldn't look twice like if i saw this
i'd be like yeah it's a backpack you
would look twice i would look twice
because i'd be like where can i get me
one of those
what's next buddy backpack fact oh my
goodness
i forgot and also andrew's here now hi
as backpacks got bigger and bigger
so did concerns that they were hurting
kids back so the industry started making
wheeled backpacks wow i'm jealous that
like i never had one in high school
i think my back is like you know eight
years older than it should be
also fun fact both of our backpacks that
we've seen so far the first two are all
made out of recycled materials that is
super cool
what's next on the agenda buddy okay so
on the agenda we're going to take a road
trip
all the way to rhode island to see a
very special
handmade backpack that's awesome oh it's
a road trip
yeah road to rhode island rhode island
yeah
hi i'm lindy mcdonough i'm the creative
director and co-founder of load of
leather in providence rhode island and
we're going to be looking at handmade
leather backpacks today
we use a fully wet white base leather so
that means that there's no chemicals no
formaldehyde no chromium we guarantee
all the bags for life
you have a lifetime guarantee yes or a
leather
bag yes that sounds crazy to me every
part of our bags are designed to be
fixed and serviced you're investing in
one from us and we're going to take care
of it for life
for you we also design them in the way
that they're going to patina and look
better
the joke is when they're brand new it's
like the worse they're going to look
and they're going to get better and
better as you use it oh that is so cool
yeah oh my god forgive me for my lack of
vocabulary but the word patina can you
just explain
patina patina is like our favorite word
that we use
it kind of tells the story of everywhere
you've been so when you put it down on
the ground or
the oils from your hands they'll start
to like yeah the color will change right
yeah so we make a couple different
backpacks but today we're going to go
through the making of the knapsack which
is one of our newer backpacks the
backpack has 48 pieces
in it so we're cutting 48 pieces out of
one skin
all the little parts are stitched they
go over to turn and burn they
essentially are tying hand-tied knots
and then burning the thread
tucking them back into the hole and then
they smooth the leather over it so it
holds
the stitch forever all of the pieces go
back and forth with stitching and
assembly until the bag is finished
all handmade all handmade that's insane
we're not trying to be the biggest
company or we are trying to make the
best bags
the vision behind the company was to
create a great job for artists
we do a 30-hour work week with full
benefits and health care and then a lot
of them
have their studio practice outside of
that whoa yeah this is so cool it's very
heartwarming i'm just like happy
okay so this knapsack obviously went
through many hands took a long time to
make how much does it cost
it costs 990 but 990. for one backpack
for the rest of your life seems pretty
good
price of a cup of coffee each day for
one year cool so you can pay in coffee
are these backpacks that you can bring
like the beach
is that okay yeah i bring my tote bags
to the beach all the time
i think the more you beat up our bags
the better they look so i'm not precious
about them they should get
used okay that's good because they're
amazing if you buy something that
expensive
i'm always scared to use it no sneakers
or
i don't know how to use it listen we
came here to beat the crap out of all
your products you should totally i'm
gonna fight some leather bags patina
before we begin patina patina new word
of the day
things that get better with time name
some uh
wine dogs human beings
usually and leather backpacks leather
backpacks okay what a natural transition
first impressions of this backpack go i
think it's just a beautiful backpack it
looks classy
it also just looks very very strong
somehow really good
it does smell good my backpack smells
like old chips
it's actually not that heavy but it has
like a heftiness to it that i appreciate
like you when you pick it up you respect
it
yeah when you open it up the smell comes
out even more
let's fill her up laptop i'm gonna put
my travel bag
which is vibrating right now because the
razor is on why is the razor on
turn it off some snacks
let's see how it feels it has all the
essentials the protractor set
tampons and a laptop okay so we're
definitely gonna have to adjust these
straps a little bit
can you do it i can't see
you wanna make it shorter right yeah a
little shorter okay thanks
i can't totally see it but i feel like
it's gotta look cool yeah that's cool
i could definitely do some damage with
this thing too if i really wanted to
you want to try it on yeah i do actually
okay i really want to try it it is just
a beautiful backpack it's hard to say
anything else functional and beautiful
just like us
it's really bad because i really want
this bag now
like i i hate this show if this one
isn't for you there's just like
a range of different backpacks you can
get so here's the zipper backpack
it's got like more of a youthful feel
it's like i could see picture students
using it
or like very wealthy young children i'm
just going to say i think this is the
most beautiful blue color
i've ever seen right this is so
beautiful it's more of a grab-and-go
type bag
oh and you can pull the straps like this
and then you have a little sling
bing bada-boom i do this doesn't feel
right i have a lot of confidence
in like these bags in terms of their
utilitarian purpose but i also just feel
like it's very special like the
emotional investment you'll get out of
getting something that's handmade
and is done with such care it just
becomes even more special for what it
like means to you as time passes yeah
it becomes a part of you yeah wow this
this backpack
adventure took us from california to new
york
to now providence rhode island i think
we've uh grown a little bit in our
patina
we've patinaed up hard baby all right i
gotta ask jen what backpack was the most
worth it to you
at this given price point this is a
really really hard question
if i'm honest it's probably low tough
just because
i tend to keep things for as long as
possible so if i were to get a bag like
that
i know i would take very good care of it
and like just grow with that bag as
silly as that sounds i get it i just
feel so
bougie what is your worth at winter
steven okay voltaic
that bag i feel like is me as a backpack
it's true fun functional cool
tech chemistry but i live in
the big apple there's big apple stores
there's energy everywhere
and for that reason flipping tumble is
the best bag for me right now
totally and it is my worth of winner you
got to be economical about space when
you're living in a place like new york
city right
annie where's the winner you're worth it
winner
thanks for taking me along this journey
friend hopefully we can have you back
i'd love to come back all right cool
we're gonna walk home now
oh my god oh my god no come back
[Music]
you